we might ask rhetorically whose taxes to
president does President Obama want to
increase the standard journalistic
responses the rich my preferred response
is Republicans Republican voters are
disproportionately wealthy and he wants
to tax Republicans to reward Democrats
they want to cut spending in order to
reduce the deficit and where would they
like to reduce spending entitlements who
disproportionately benefits from
entitlements the relatively poor who
disproportionately vote Democrat the
Republicans want to punish the Democrats
to reward their constituents the
Democrats want to punish the Republicans
to reward theirs how might we fix this
well it would be nice for example if we
the people elected the Congress instead
of the members of Congress choosing who
their voters will be gerrymandering
ensures that the Congress gets to pick
its voters rather the other way around
so the probability of being reelected as
an incumbent in the Congress is 95
percent almost as high as it was in the
old Soviet Union of being reelected to
their Parliament we've got a rigged
system we could fix that there are lots
of excellent political science studies
on how to design redistricting so that
it's completely nonpartisan it's
entirely one-person one-vote subject to
Geographic constraints and topology we
could write computer programs that do
redistricting now no member of Congress
is going to agree to that in the short
term because that would put her or his
hold on power at risk but if we were to
pass a law that says starting in 20
years or 25 years this program will be
used to do redistricting we would have
solved the problem of the voters not
choosing their members of Congress and
that will go a long way to altering the
risk of being thrown out of office if
you don't do what the what the people
want and we'd get much better policy but
that's very far down the road shorter
term also hard to do we could get rid of
the electoral college it's it's useful
to remember
that you know when people speak about
standing by the original Constitution
and so forth being strict
constitutionalists the Electoral College
was designed as a slavery institution we
got rid of slavery he we haven't gotten
rid of this slavery institution we ought
to that too would ensure that the
presidents would be more responsive to a
still larger coalition and that would
mean doing more of what we the people
want